jackie chan is beloved but he has
released as many flops to smash hits did
anyone really need to see him crap
falling his way around the world in 80
days keep watching for more of his best
and worst
not many people would disagree that
jackie chan found true mass appeal with
rush hour his notoriety had already
begun to spread into the western
hemisphere before the movie was released
in 1998 but it was this hilarious buddy
cop hit which catapulted jackie into the
upper echelons of stardom in rush hour
chum plays a hong kong detective brought
over to the los angeles area to help
track down an old nemesis in an attempt
to get him out of their hair the local
police force pairs him up with detective
carter who recently botched a vital
operation and was due for some form of
punishment there are so many delightful
elements that made this buddy cop movie
work while the plot may be a little
simplistic its straightforward formula
allows the stars to really shine shannon
is in top form at this point a veteran
of action cinema who is still young
enough to tumble through obstacles and
sail through the air the juxtaposition
of chan's regimented detectives speaking
in rigid english with tucker's lanky
fountain of jokester diatribes also
makes for a hilarious double act thank
you thank you um what the hell are you
doing
i just being polite well next time
people liked my nuts
in short rush hour is a movie that
reminds you why you love movies and
easily stands up as one of jackie chan's
best the medallion fell victim to the
same monster that many early 2000s films
did it was wooed by the overwhelming
allure of new age cgi unfortunately the
filmmakers failed to recognize who they
had on board for this film namely the
king of fight choreography and stunt
work instead they opted to replace all
his combat experience with cheesy
computer animated super powers the film
struggles to find an identity most of
the way through stumbling over awkward
attempts at humor missing entirely on
moments of sincerity and failing to
properly utilize this action star even
in jackie chan's lesser movies it's easy
to let go and have fun because he always
looks like he's having fun too but
that's not the case here the medallion
is a big choppy cgi backflip followed by
a face plant into the dirt
it was around the release of rumble in
the bronx that insurance companies were
getting nervous about ensuring jackie
chan and watching this movie will make
it pretty obvious why that was the case
chan is known for performing his own
stunts rumble and the bronx features
some of his most daring of all in this
1995 movie chum plays a hong kong cup on
vacation for his uncle's wedding in new
york things take a turn for the worst
however when the grocery store his uncle
just sold falls victim to a protection
racket from a local biker gang the hero
decides to fight back out of a misguided
sense of nobility leading him to face
off against hordes of ruthless bikers
and mobsters the movie itself is pretty
low budget but you'll rarely notice
thanks to jackie's incredible fighting
choreography and death defying stunts
the action star is in peak form here
with so much energy it practically
bubbles up out of him and onto the
screen the elaborate battle sequences
highlight his ability to use his
surroundings too as he fights back with
everything around him rumble in the
bronx is a testament to both jackie
chan's action skills and his star power
and this still holds up all these years
later
if you've ever had a fever dream
involving john cusack crossing swords
with jackie chan then prepare to have
your mind blown the sheer absurdity of
dragonblade delivers a sliver of joy but
sadly fails to rescue the movie from
being a colossal dern other than the
novelty of some of the action most of
dragonblade falls flat once again the
downfall of any jackie chan flick is its
creator's inability to utilize their
stars properly bizarrely the cast is
backed up by not just john cusack but
also adrian brodie and no part of the
script offers any suggestion as to why
they climbed on board this disaster
still the fight sequences at least put
chan's abilities on full display showing
that he's got some juice left in the
tank a few sparks of life fail to ignite
the fuse on this lackluster ride though
there's very little story to follow and
the little there is tends to be driven
by cringe-worthy cliches best to skip
out on this one
the best part of the legend of drunken
master is getting to see a fresh face
jackie chan fully embrace his strengths
while his martial arts abilities are
dazzling it's chan's animated
expressions and gift for physical comedy
that sets him apart from his
counterparts and this kung fu sequel is
chan's first film to fully lean into
this jackie plays wang feihung the son
to a local merchant who mistakenly mixes
up a prescription of ginseng root with a
fellow traveler's chinese artifact his
attempts to cover up his mistake only
result in further disaster as it turns
out however wang is adept in the art of
drunken boxing and becomes an
increasingly adept fighter the more
inebriated he becomes
do you think that's a good idea don't
worry it gives him power the legend of
drunken master is arguably one of chan's
best displays of physical comedy while
the first film was pretty fun to watch
this sequel is more fully formed indeed
there are a few other jackie chan films
that so adeptly utilize every element of
the actor's talent
the buddy cop genre is a tried and true
formula that leads straight to america's
hearts unfortunately even the greats can
make a wrong turn or two skip trace
teams jackie chan up with goofball
supreme johnny knox film you might
assume that funny plus funny would equal
hysterical but there are apparently some
diminishing returns at play here once
again jackie plays a hong kong detective
and once again he is paired up with an
apathetic american the two follow a
trail of cliches to a predictable ending
proving once and for all that anytime a
chan vehicle fails to deliver it's down
to lackluster rising because whenever
it's time for a fight you can't help but
fall in love just like most shaky chan
films you'll at least get some
entertainment value out of skip trace
but that's about all you'll get
it speaks volumes about jackie chan's
work ethic that in the same year he led
a blockbuster hit alongside chris tucker
he also wrote and directed who am i this
absolutely named film stars jackie as a
special forces operative who suffers
amnesia after his aircraft crashes in
the south african jungle after spending
weeks living among the natives and
recuperating he hitches a ride with a
cross-country rally car team to
johannesburg simultaneously embarking
upon a journey of self-discovery in who
am i chan is a merely a lovable kung fu
hero he's a character with genuine
layers filled with plenty of potential
for emotional resonance the
responsibility of directing did nothing
to slow down chan's lust for thrilling
action sequences either and to ami
feature some of the coolest action
scenes in the actor's filmography
to put it bluntly around the world in 80
days is a serious disappointment the
beloved jules verne classic was ripe for
adaptation but disney wrapped their
talons around it and took off in totally
the wrong direction rather than remain
true to the source material they
attempted to transform it into a jackie
chan movie and while there's obviously
nothing wrong with a jackie chan movie
you can't force what isn't there with a
massive budget you can at least say that
the movie does look decent but this does
nothing to disguise the fact that every
attempt at humor falls flat on its face
the endless pratfalls and terrible line
deliveries start to become genuinely
annoying after a while too in the end
the only thing around the world in 80
days really achieves is making you feel
sorry for the actors involved
i can tell when we're not wanted
by the time shanghai noon was released
in 2000 it appeared that jackie chan was
trying to find new challenges for
himself next on the list apparently was
a good old-fashioned american western in
this movie chan plays chon wang an
imperial guard from the forbidden city
in the late 19th century on a mission to
retrieve a princess who has been taken
hostage by a defector early in his
journey wang meets owen wilson's outlaw
royal bannon the two form an unlikely
alliance with o'bannon teaching wang the
ways of the west as they navigate a
xenophobic and highly dangerous
landscape shanghai noon is a great
action comedy that bears most of jackie
chan's fights with the dry owen wilson
narrating exclamations on the sidelines
this offbeat genre casting doesn't seem
like it should work but it does even
better shanghai noon doesn't take itself
too seriously at all making it all the
easier to sit back and have fun with it
the tuxedo is easily one of jackie
chan's most disappointing films the
concept seems cute on paper but is
executed so poorly that it almost has
you rooting against its lead usually
movie audiences are willing to take a
walk in fantasyland when it comes to
convenient plot devices but they're
technologically enhanced tuxedo ploy
falls flat from the moment chan slips
into his penguin suit in this movie chan
plays a limo driver charged with driving
a debonair bomb type when his passenger
is put out of commission when he puts on
the man's tuxedo however he discovers
that it enhances his combat skills and
turns him into an accidental secret
agent unfortunately that tuxedo is so
heavily overproduced that a shiny veneer
actually dulls jackie chan's raw star
power the only thing this camby flop
does is show that even after losing 90
minutes of your lives to utter
mediocrity you're probably still willing
to forgive a star as lovable as chan
the third entry in the police story
series finds jackie chan reprising his
role as its resident supercop to go
undercover and infiltrate a major drug
rink supercop marks the beginning of
jackie's transition to hollywood from
the hong kong film market
it takes all the high-flying jackie chan
panache and adds a big heaping scoop of
old-school pyrotechnics and plenty of
gunfire to boot
at times jackie chan movies can take a
careless approach to story structure
opting instead for playful banter as a
means of filling the void between action
sequences supercop avoids this flaw
however instead blending all the
necessary elements of a truly great
action flick the physical comedy
transcends the language barrier the
story is intriguing and the stunts will
make you just the right kind of nervous
hong kong action movies don't get much
more fun than this
the route for every action megastar
eventually passes through kid-friendly
territory and no plot device is more
familiar than the secret agent getting
stuck babysitting a bunch of kids
perhaps that's why the spy next door
feels so exhaustingly trite right from
the opening credits jackie plays an
ex-spy looking to settle down in
suburbia when his next door neighbor
girlfriend needs to go out of town
inevitably he offers to watch after her
three kids and hilarity ensues or at
least it should ensue not only is the
spy next door wildly unoriginal but the
jackie chan of this movie seems totally
drained of the childish joy for which he
has known and loved in fact the spy next
door falls flat in every department and
the action sequences in particular are a
grim reminder of a sad truth that jackie
chan is getting old truth is there are
much better chan movies out there this
one just isn't worth your time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stars are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]